hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to you can keep or I think
that's what it spelled just for doing
the dual as the secret is that it's
Pikachu spelled backwards and this is a
reminiscent remedy of horror story told
in the world of Pokemon way back in the
day now I'm not a big fan of Pokemon
today but I was a big fan of Pokemon
when original red-blue came out because
I was just a little child and I watched
all of the TV show oh no random battle
there's probably gonna be great
hey it's Machop while Machop appeared I
wonder kind of kept our Pokemon I got
what do I do
a bundle I press okay alright then go oh
did I won I got a chill up my spine did
a 100 no not another one runaway Pokemon
ok keep it's gonna kill you oh boy oh ok
keep oh if you couldn't tell I think
this is made by the same guy that made
sonic dot exe and
was yelling I don't even remember Luka
keep ray fun for the whole family the
children are all gonna enjoy when they
see their Louisville yellow little
friend murder every other Pokemon in the
world there's like this horror story I
don't know what specific creepypasta
this based on but this or what the hell
was that you want to talk about that for
a second okay it's not actually a horror
story it's just talking about how people
in the Pokemon world eat cuz obviously
they don't eat cows yo I got a choice oh
I got a choice each oice oh I got the
choice you've her choice east of choices
oh wait no there's not what I wanted you
jolted me over to the left oh okay okay
so why am I doing this and why is this
looping forever
I died what does it even mean why did I
die oh okay
I made the wrong choice apparently so I
gotta go make a right choice so that is
what that is all about let's try this
one I wonder if it will end in my death
probably I'm gonna get the right one I
get it you could keep your creepy
son-of-a-bitch but that doesn't mean
anything to be because I'm gonna be just
fine over here
you go [ __ ] yourself all right you went
straight down what else was I supposed
to assume that you were supposed to do
okay take one of these call me in the
morning except don't because [ __ ] you
that'll be the right choice go do
hi-yah I died great fun for me I'm so
happy of that fact well I think there's
only one other Avenue to go so I think
we're gonna be just fine for our odds of
getting to the right place in this
goddamn game
okay
oh did I still do the right one
goddamnit I was wandering that thing
forever so one now my heart's still
beating that means I'm still alive or
it's been ripped out of my chest
oh I'm red now oh oh I can't go that way
I gotta follow the direction of the
blood I've officially turned into the
real red who's actually a character if
you don't know much about pokemons well
I'm guessing you do because I'm one of
the few people that don't know a lot
about the new generations of Pokemon not
that he's new he's old very old but
either way okay I'm not moving
oh hi are you oka keep to be continued
why oh god damn it I went all this way
oh who's that god damn it I went all
this way for nothing because it's gonna
be a son of a [ __ ] and call sequel what
is it
damn you you piece of [ __ ] that better
be the last of it
you better be done now okay I think it's
done so that was okay keep otherwise
known as Pikachu dot exe so there you go
for that all that fun so let me know
what you think of the comments below it
is some good jump scares I guess
whatever but you can check out the
others like sonic dot exe and whatever
the other one not exe was and if there's
any more dotting says one I'll put him
in the description so thank you again
everybody for watching as always I'll
see you in the next video bye bye sal is
gonna do huh boy
Oh son of a [ __ ]
you